[Music]
oh man I'm so excited this is the first
time I'm going to comic-con and I'm
going to go incognito nobody's going to
see me let's go see how it works out
[Music]
what I'm chef Judy
Wow and he talks just like
and as you can see I love what has been
your favorite part so far I was hoping
the experience okay I'm not going out
with Freddie can you purchase these you
just made my David looking this is dope
oh you can buy the hi I'm here with
Ashley and Anna and we're trying to
figure out they can guess what kind of
costume I have on
it's supposed to be nerds because we're
here at Comic Con and we're going to see
so what do you got
you look like
you're not big but I don't know she
really said big bird that bird is yellow
how can you be at all - it doesn't make
any sense today was an amazing day I had
an awesome time at comic-con manda
everything was great so I'm gonna end
today with my two favorite superheroes
fireman I had the hope and you can't
forget about the best one of all
Superman see you guys next year
[Music]
you